it has been way too much blame way too
much finger-pointing way too much
politicizing and fear and panic and
hysteria on the coronavirus ton of fake
news misinformation going around once
again we on this program we are going to
be dedicated to bringing you facts
without fear we are Americans we will
start this program every night with the
facts first without fear will call out
those that are so corrupt that have
nothing but a political agenda that
would include the media mob many of them
and we can sum it up by the way very
beginning of this virus New York Times
headline the Trump virus if you feel
awful you know who to blame other
multiple outlets calling it Trump's
Katrina Trump's Chernobyl we're gonna
analyze the destructive irresponsible
behavior of the mob and the Democratic
Party but first we're gonna start with
the facts without fear why to help keep
your family our American family safe and
healthy I hope one day we get rid of
cancer and heart disease that people we
lose tens of thousands of people who
have flu every year we want everybody
safe and and healthy and and sound we
start tonight with breaking news I've
spent a considerable amount of time now
speaking with leaders all weekend and
today from the president's Task Force
here's where we are this very moment is
a critical time for everybody in the
country my sources are very clear
tonight we are now entering what will be
the crucial defining 15-day period as a
rose as a relate to this virus where we
must slow the spread of coronavirus and
if we all join as Americans the virus
doesn't discriminate against Republican
Democrat liberal or conservative does it
if we can do this for 15 days thousands
of American lives will be saved look at
your screen these are the
recommendations from the task force and
the administration for all Americans if
you feel sick stay at home if your kids
feel sick do not send them to school or
daycare if someone in your household has
tested positive for corona virus please
self quarantine your entire household
keep them at home if you are an older
person or an individual with underlying
medical conditions a compromised immune
system maybe you're receiving
chemotherapy radiation have Auto
immune issues whatever the underlying
diseases are please stay away almost
quarantine yourself from other people it
is critically important we heed these
guidelines especially in this 15-day
period starting today if everybody does
their part in the next two weeks we know
for a fact lives will be saved don't be
afraid to be vigilant if you need more
information there's the website corona
virus dot-gov we'll put it up later in
the program as the president said
earlier today our key main focus must be
slowing the spread of this disease and
now for the 15-day period the president
is asking all Americans even those that
well don't like a single thing he's done
let's all join together in this effort
my administration is recommending that
all Americans including the young and
healthy work to engage in schooling from
home when possible avoid gathering in
groups of more than 10 people avoid
discretionary travel and avoid eating
and drinking at bars restaurants and
public food courts if everyone makes
this change or these critical changes
and sacrifices now we will rally
together as one nation and we will
defeat the virus and we're going to have
a big celebration all together
presidents right we're fighting an
invisible enemy and now slowing the
spread is crucial it is key luckily in
this case some pretty basic steps by all
of us together will go a very long way
for example many Americans are now
working remotely thank God for
technology numerous schools universities
they are utilizing online learning
another great progress thousands of bars
restaurants across the country are now
limiting service to takeout and delivery
I want these guys to keep staying in
business so I'm trying to I'm trying to
patronize all the businesses I know
anyway tonight especially local business
it's critically important that you
practice great hygiene and what we call
social distancing and according to the
studies this virus is three times more
contagious than the flu from the
beginning if you remember our coverage
we were telling you we notice that
people with virtually no symptoms or
none what so
ever they were capable of unknowingly
pass it passing it on to others and
while most young people unlike h1n1 well
they don't experience sometimes no
symptoms or not severe symptoms mild
symptoms they can spread this disease
like wildfire and the overwhelming
people that do contract the disease
again no symptoms mild symptoms or
you'll get the flu of a fully recover
and if they by the way or around those
with those underlying conditions
compromised immune systems and they pass
on this virus we risk losing those lives
that's why this is important as I've
been saying let's protect our
grandmothers our grandparents our older
moms and dads that's what this 15-day
period is all about look we're the land
of the free and the home of the brave
though that these are not just words in
an anthem because that is who we are as
a people it's in our DNA
I always say let not your hearts be
troubled we're going to get through this
during its first inaugural address you
may remember President Roosevelt
reassuring Americans during a time of
great uncertainty saying the only thing
we have to fear is fear itself fear is
not helping here those advancing
political agendas they're not helping
either
86 years later those words they still
ring true today in a few short decades
this country defeated it let's see
Nazism fascism communism Imperial Japan
we made it through a Great Depression
the Great Recession 9/11 the Cold War
where the American people we face our
problems head-on rise to the occasion
overcome our challenges no matter what
with the greatest best medical
researchers scientists doctors in the
entire world
the corona virus is no different so far
there have been under 200,000 confirmed
cases worldwide it was one thousand one
hundred eighty one thousand three
hundred and seventy seven I have an
updated number right there anyway at
more than seven thousand deaths the goal
is to save as many lives here in America
and worldwide as possible at home in
America three thousand eight hundred
Americans have tested positive for the
disease again facts without fear less
than 100 have died those numbers will
rise likely dramatic
with more testing or the numbers have
that of contracted the disease it is
that expected if everybody does their
part it will level off the sooner the
better
and for context a lot of people don't
seem to know this and this is why the
fear-mongering and the panic and the
hype and hysteria is so unhelpful last
year over 35 million Americans
contracted the flu over four hundred
ninety thousand Americans hospitalized
for the flu 34,000 Americans died of the
flu right here in the United States over
the course of just one year and that's
pretty typical now thankfully the toll
surrounding coronavirus is lower
however facts without fear if we take
all the necessary precautions the stats
will level off and ultimately begin a
decline in hopefully four to six weeks
max and get back to life as normal
tonight we all must do whatever is
necessary to stop the spread of the
disease
protect our older fellow Americans
flatten that curve and more importantly
save lives we can't say this tonight
without a doubt the president's China
and European travel ban I predict will
go down as the single most consequential
decision in history
that's not political it brought us time
it bought hospitals time to prepare for
the worst case scenario it bought the
federal government time to source
ventilators and other medical supplies
it bought doctors scientists researchers
time to develop either treatments and
eventually hopefully a vaccine it bought
the pharmaceutical industry time so they
can do what they do best in fact the
very first experimental vaccine in the
u.s. was tested today earlier today and
let's not forget it also bought enough
time for an unprecedented public-private
partnership to form as the president
announced Friday I would say between
within three weeks of us identifying the
virus then the travel ban quarantine
this unprecedented public-private
partnership where we're gonna go to
parking lots of Walmart's Walgreens CVS
I don't want to forget all the great
companies that are helping and we're now
going to be able to do something we've
never been able to do before
Kirt speed a groundbreaking new system a
new paradigm drive-through testing sites
is in the works now all across the
country with many locations already open
in record time today even the medium mob
they showed maybe they were sick today
slight signs of moderate restraint it
wasn't all gotcha questions and personal
attacks however sadly there are those
who will always be more interested in
bludgeoning the president politically
than actually solving a problem in this
case a pandemic
sadly pandemics happen I wish they never
happen which brings us to the politics
of this virus context is important in
life so take a look at this timeline
this is different and put together by
Joel Pollock look at this January 21st
the very first person with coronavirus
arrived in the u.s. from China that's
not long ago the same time Democrats
what were they doing they were in the
throes of an all-consuming what has been
a culmination of a three-year quest to
impeach at throw Donald Trump out of
office unto an election they never
accepted the results of in the beginning
January 23rd house impeachment managers
what were they doing oh they were doing
their opening arguments and impeachment
same day China completely sealed off the
entire province of Wuhan
then on January 31st look at this the
president then declared that national
health emergency ordered mandatory
two-week warranties he issued the travel
ban on all travel to and from China and
on that same day what the Democrats
doing
they were busy with impeaching the
president they weren't caring January
31st Senate Democrats desperately
pushing for more impeachment witnesses
the day that Donald Trump put the travel
ban quarantine in effect Wow wasn't
until February 5th that the impeachment
charade was officially over and even
then many were plotting future
impeachment investigations the next one
meanwhile other top Democrats they were
calling the president's travel ban
racist On January 31st the day of the
travel ban what did quid-pro-quo Joe say
about the president's actions he said
they were xenophobic they were
hysterical and the president was
fear-mongering no Joe you're wrong
Democrat House members they were worried
that the band would stoke racial
discrimination look at your screen no
president has done war or acted quicker
to stop the spread of a pandemic or a
disease and yet president's been trashed
every step of the way by Democrats and
of course their state-run TV in the
media Bob take a look we're working very
strongly with China on the corona virus
this is no time for Donald Trump's
record of hysteria xenophobia I have
today declared that the corona virus
presents a public health emergency in
the United States we have a crisis of
coronavirus and president Trump has no
plan so we've stopped non-us citizens
from coming into America from China that
was done very early on we're screening
people and we have been at a very high
level we're working very hard to
expedite the longer process of
developing a vaccine we have to just
stipulate to fact we have to dispel some
of the misinformation that has been put
out there to unleash the full power of
the federal government that this effort
today I am officially declaring a
national emergency to shut this
president up right now because he is
undermining the doctors and the
scientists who are trying to help the
American people and it last night stall
boring debate you had dr. quid pro quo
Joe and dr. Bolshevik Bernie Sanders
making it abundantly clear they never
would have enacted a travel ban to stop
the spread of coronavirus that would
have been the single biggest mistake
that would have resulted in thousands of
Americans contracting the disease and
untold numbers dying they want
completely open borders even still
unchecked immigration they both want
government-run free health care for all
including illegal immigrants yeah this
is going to be very expensive at the end
of the day those two bozos they didn't
quite get it and it's likely thousands
of Americans would have contracted the
virus and many other Americans die from
it America's borders as we've been
saying have got to be safe testing
screening those who come into our
country
that's one aspect of it also we don't
want people with radical agendas we want
people that are able to take care of
themselves if we do invite them into our
country to be part of our American
family we don't care where you come from
just let us vet you our health care
system all not perfect produces the best
doctors medicine research anywhere in
the world but dr. quid pro quo Joe is
now telling voters that he would have
done a much better job as president that
his socialist ideas of oh he wants to
expand Obamacare millions lost their
doctors millions lost their plans and on
average were paying 200% more and 37
percent of Americans have one
obama-biden care exchange option this is
the same guy who can't even get through
a digital Town Hall on Saturday without
turning it into a complete and total
disaster and shift show take a look but
the whole point of this is that we can
do a lot to deal with endangered species
and one of the things I would like to
raise is that we have to deal with this
on an international basis as well
because right now for example we have a
thing you know Brazil has the the Amazon
is burning because well I'm sorry this
has been such a disjointed effort here
because of the connections but there's a
lot more to say but I've already
probably said too much to you now in 232
days you the American people saw all the
cameras over here oh it doesn't say
Hannity for president or anything to
cover it up a disaster then started like
two and a half hours late 232 days you
will decide whether that man holds the
keys to the most powerful job in the
world a critical decision we are now
witnessing the president's actions can
have major and massive ramifications
this new paradigm let's see-oh
public-private partnerships travel bans
quarantine acting in unprecedented with
unprecedented quickness this will now
change how we deal with future pandemics
and save lives the regulation cutting is
helping speed the development of a
vaccine the emergency declaration
enabled an unprecedented public-private
partnership with all the money that will
be needed to fund it and going forward
the President's commitment to helping
American businesses will
while lasting effects gotta help our
fellow businesses that are in trouble
airline industry cruise industry those
workers hourly workers have fear taken a
day or a couple of days off because
they're not feeling well they're all
handled under the president's plan
already listening to drill well I have a
plan well the President did all the
things you were talking about and then
some now is not the time for Washington
to play games all hands on deck
governor's mayor's the federal
government must now work together get
hospitals what they need the equipment
that might be needed the supplies that
they may in need in the future
newt gingrich had a great idea use the
floating naval vessels that we already
have we already have floating hospitals
we can use those maybe we could even
commandeer or rent or buy temporarily
maybe these cruise ships rather than
just the bailout we can house people
that need help of course we're not at
that point we don't want to get to that
point we need to prepare for the
worst-case scenario president and his
task force confirm they are now as it
stands our health care system as
adequate ventilators ICU beds medical
professionals and ultimately like I said
we must prepare for the worst pray for
the best
in the meantime wash your hands stay at
home